you have easily the best background yeah
is that is that metal your stuff looks
cool dude look at what you got going on
there um it is a little it's not metal
but it's like um uh it's it's it's
really cool actually i'm gonna give them
problems
yeah
it's from a company called hot toys um
they make really cool stuff uh a lot of
questions for you guys um i'm curious
this is going to be the i like to throw
a curve ball for my first question for
both of you if someone has never seen
anything that you've done before what's
the first thing you want them to watch
and why
that's a great question you go first
i've done too many things let me
um okay with the first thing of mine
oh this is a tough question that's a
tough question okay i i mean i would say
maybe it'd be christmas i mean it's got
it's if you're looking for a comedy with
winslow fegli i would i would recommend
eight pixels it's a great movie
um and then also i was in you know timmy
failure i played timmy failure and
that's a great disney movie
um
it was awesome
that's an awesome movie as well
you picked two things you picked two if
you keep going and now we're gonna get
to three i'm
joking
but i i would recommend you for
christmas for sure
sure
for me i would say
i hosted the tony awards in 2015 and i
did this number called bigger where we
were back in radio city music hall and i
i had i got to do just kind of a little
bit of everything i got to
to sing i jumped through a hoop i did a
magic trick i i i it was a crazy thing
it was short right so you wouldn't have
to you'd go ruse's nearby and then you'd
see it and i think you'd you'd get a
good uh representation of the nonsense
that i seem to do on the regular
before i jump into talking to you about
8-bit christmas uh neil i just have to
ask you an individual question um
did you think when you got called about
being in a matrix movie that someone was
punking you or did you actually believe
it was real
uh that's a really interesting question
i i didn't think i was being punked but
i didn't know that i was
being uh speaking to uh lana about a
matrix movie it was very very hush-hush
the whole thing so it was really a sort
of a chemistry conversation with the
director lana wachowski uh about just
vibing
and i assumed it may be for that but i
wasn't told it was for that so it was it
i i was my own red pill rabbit down the
rabbit hole moment of of
of getting to know someone i'd never met
in a very like succinct way
and i guess it went well because i i got
a small part in the movie
couldn't be more excited for that film
um winslow before you made this movie
did you even know what a nintendo nes
was
yeah i mean i i'm i'm kind of a video
game geek
um
and
i knew about you know
um the nes and i knew
about you know the switch and nintendo
of courses in general but um
you know i kind of i have the switch and
i've seen you know like the little baby
grand
son of the
of the nes and
um
yeah it was a lot of fun like just like
seeing how important it was and
influential it was and getting to play
around with it and um
just like seeing
the whole thing it was awesome yeah i
would argue the nes is um is beyond
important to the history of video games
but for both of you guys um i felt like
this movie has a like a real christmas
story vibe to it you know in terms of
but just for a different genera for a
new generation that is about video games
can you sort of talk about that that
energy of the film
that's why i signed up for it mate i
read the script and i thought this is
very much on brand with christmas story
which is one of my favorite all-time
movies definitely a christmas perennial
uh favorite
and i loved the vo i loved that
that it was smart that it was that it
had like
clever dialogue for both the
contemporary adult part and the
uh and the throwback kids parts it
seemed like something i would want to
uh be in want to watch and want to show
my kids so
uh
yeah on brand and i and i think well i
think we hit the mark it's surprisingly
more
um sentimental than i thought it would
be when i read the script because
christmas story is kind of
acerbic and a little bit a little bit uh
like a darker indie christmas film in
its own way right but this one feels a
little more
warm and fuzzy in the right way the kind
of thing that you want to watch with
your kids and and say oh that was a
really good movie i liked it so proud of
it
uh for both of you guys and like like
everybody when you and winslow you're
still a kid but when you were even
younger um i'm curious what was the
thing that you both were desperate to
get i'm sure you've answered this before
but like the thing that you would have
literally cut off your right arm to own
well
i don't know so well last year i really
wanted an oculus quest
and i got an oculus quest which was
really nice and super cool it's a vr
um
and
[Music]
then
also i've kind of always wanted to you
know
build like a crazy robot
or something um and i do that a lot i
build robots and stuff
i have a lot of fun doing that stuff i
love that your answer is is a virtual
reality system
because my answer was going to be a
snake
and you know in a in a like one of those
aquarium like a snake and i never got
one of those because you had to feed it
like frozen mice or something and then
no one like this the idea of the snake
one and then defeating the snake seemed
like it was never going to be a good
time but
yeah vr is much cooler
there's the difference in generations
right there you know i think well i also
want a dog i want a dog this christmas
right
yeah but winslow are you going to be
willing to walk the dog even when it's
cold outside well
well here they'll be playing vr right
exactly
wait
that's so true um for both of you i'm
not sure neil if you're a video game
person i know you have kids maybe they
are
for both of you guys if you could only
like keep a game or two on an island
what what are those games that you have
to have oh that's a great question
i buy all of the video game systems and
i have for a long time and i play them
almost never because i'm so excited
about the hype and i got and i'm able
back then i was a working kid actor
right so i could afford to to
to get the cool game quickly but then i
didn't have the time to really play it
but what would i choose i'd choose one
of the open world things right now i'd
probably choose like a legend of zelda e
kind of thing that you oh
what about red dead redemption
yeah that's kind of a good game see i
bought the ps5
not i didn't buy i was given a ps5 for a
gift
dude i know
i haven't played it one time i might as
well sell the thing on ebay because you
can make a gun give it to me give it to
me
i'm kidding okay well no i won't but
what but i don't have the time because
these games are so huge now
that i i
what am i supposed to do am i going to
sit up in my attic and play ps5 if once
you start a game you're going to play it
for 47 000 hours but if i was on an
island i'd probably play red dead
redemption and
like one of those super mario world
things with a bunch of mini games
yeah i would i would play um
i would bring minecraft for sure it's my
all-time favorite game oh that's a good
answer it
always will be
play it all the time
and then i would also probably bring
uh
well i'll bring my quest and i would
play like
one of the zombie games or something
like there's no sunshine or something
because i love like that stuff that's so
cool
on that note i need to stop i'm just
going to say congrats on the movie i
really do hope it's a big hit for you
guys thank you for your time thanks
you